what do you wish more people knew about
movie making that maybe they just don't
know
uh i i hope they never learned anything
about moviemaking
i hope they never know i hope they never
see who's behind the curtain you know i
i think if they don't want to be a
filmmaker if they don't get into the
business and they just have they just
want to be entertained or want to be
transported somewhere
else it's best not to know too much
because you don't want to knock down
that proverbial fourth wall you want to
keep yourself safe and secure from any
knowledge other than what the story is
is throwing throwing back at you but of
course there's a whole other subset of
individuals who want to tell their
stories and they're telling them right
now on their iphones they're telling
them right now on social media and on
twitter and i mean on instagram and on
tiktok and
and uh and i have my eye out for them
all the time because that is those are
the individuals that
should know
what goes into
preparing a script and the only only
piece of advice i don't have not a lot
of time but the only piece of advice i
love to give
is don't worry so much about technique
and don't worry so much about where to
put the camera or how to light
worry about one thing or think about one
thing preoccupy yourself with how do you
tell a story that's really interesting
that you can get somebody not to walk
out of the room right in the middle of
your second act of your telling the
story how do you just tell a story
that that that people lean into what
you're saying and they don't lean back
they'll like start looking around the
room
find a way first a
compelling way to express your art
through your storytelling once you've
got that there's a lot of people in this
world that will get around you and and
show you the ropes but
learning how to be a storyteller is the
most important advice i can give you
you